hello how are you I'm good how are you
nice to meet you Justin nice to see I
don't have any hair done I have been
here for two years two years yeah it'll
be two years I'm sorry yeah and is your
father gonna buy your hotel
never hurt gonna happen even if I was
like me as I want it just cuz I'm bored
not gonna happen
I would recommend do you wanna start
with an appetizer maybe yeah what's the
super day broccoli cauliflower yeah okay
I'll try let's go for the face to what I
straight okay man it's a huge menu
hammers in the kitchen to two chefs
hmm how'd you get this food fresh with
only two shots in the kitchen and a menu
with literally 3540 dishes on it you
don't need our menu here is huge
I wish we could use better ingredients
here in the van and Reno they don't want
to spend I would not spend my money here
at the restaurant no I think the food
sucks how am i they say you're always
running around yeah crazy I don't give
you a general manager I'm two years two
years
no disrespect you don't look like a
general manager right I'm not that
anymore yeah [ __ ]
seriously seriously did your falling out
with them because know everybody's
incompetent apparently
I'm sick of not really being the general
manager I kind of feel like I'm being
pulled in all different directions I
don't really have a say in anything how
would you describe the illness Vanda is
borderline sociopath the other one I
don't know I can't describe her she's
never here so I appreciate you want to
say thank you wife Mandy seems pissed I
suppose if I was working as hard as she
is and the owners thought the staff were
the problem I'd be pissed too right
what's your new drink thank you
thank you so far taste it
just a small bit
look
mmm-hmm it is absolutely [ __ ]
disgusting does chef not care
I don't think the cooks care anymore but
I feel like a lot of us have gotten to
that point okay what I fish trip which
isn't a strip it's like a ball honestly
I've never had it because I don't like
it is it fresh well frozen frozen but it
looks like crap so I wouldn't eat at
first that's what it takes yeah I mean
we almost closed everything who's the
most assertive other sisters founder cuz
Elena's not here no have commited
holidays are running the business don't
care I think they look at it as like
well I own it so we can do whatever we
want sleep till 3:00 in the afternoon
keep the bar open till 5:00 in the
morning I mean how do you respect
somebody who does that oh no no no no no
can you have any owners and chefs yeah
thank you though
you're welcome the food here is horrific
it's as if the chef is cooking in her
sleep putting one's talked to us
now you don't need me here to tell you
the soup is that disgusting that even
before anybody tasting it it smells
burnt this is where we make our own food
you giving up young lady do you hate
food what's going on they used to love
my job
and now I hate it
I can see what's not working for you any
honors gonna tolerate disrespect you
know we're not getting paid we're not
paying our staff John as owners complain
about not being paper you [ __ ] owe
your place
they don't have ownership of this
historic building either daddy's not
paying everything
can I tell you something Gordon jen has
called herself the best cook in town
she's tall they're picking on her you
have turned every [ __ ] member of
staff against you I used to be really
chirpy and happy and I
I can't even smile anymore it's not
about you can't even motivate myself to
do my project again just listen to both
of you you're only as good as the team
underneath you
whether you were here three months a
[ __ ] year or three hours a day it
doesn't matter yeah
[Music]